foreign
welcome back everyone and um
we were talking about vertex specifier
and what I would do is just to tell you
how to construct a voltage specifier for
some concrete problem called min max
path okay and we will see later how
vertex classifier in the black stock
manner
like box manner can give you Dynamic
algorithm
okay and what we have seen is like
definition of min max path which is just
um a path with minimum max weight
here the min max pass from SCT is seven
and the important thing that we just
need to remember is that
if you want to specify the graph
you can specify the graph into a tree
and this minimum second entry
preserves every min max path between
every pair of nodes
Okay so
now let's try to construct vertex
specifier from index pass problem
okay so the problem precisely is this
right you have a graph and you have a
terminal set s
you want to construct a graph
ish
of size linear in s
and at the same time
um for every pair UV
every terminal pair
min max
of UV in h and in G
this is preserved exactly
and then we just write H equivalent to G
with respect to s
okay
just for warming up
um
suppose that
your terminal set is just
um you have two nodes
u and v
how should we construct the graph Edge
anyone
so you just construct one Edge UV and
how should it be the way just be the
mean next of this like you can be okay
good good okay
um
now let's see um in the general case how
it should be
well the algorithm will be like this
okay let's start with Computing a
minimum spending tree of a graph
and it's safe to do that like and we can
just focus on these three because it
preserves our min max path
of our community
and let's say that this
purple thing is a terminal set
okay
let's focus on these three
next thing I would do
which is quite convenient is to compute
the LCA closure of the terminal set in a
tree
so and call it S Prime so what I mean
what do I mean by this it's just that
the OCA closure is like for everything
in unv
in S Prime the LCA of unv is in S Prime
as well
so
I want this thing and that uh S Prime
contain s
and in picture
it would be like this so just look at
the LCA of every purple thing and it
look at the LCA and add it
here is the lcscn edit and so on and
it's easy to see that you will add like
the size of S Prime will be just twice
as much as is
the compute S Prime
and then
once you get S Prime
you can like we can like kind of Define
adjacent pair of two not in S Prime like
these two guys are adjusting because
there is no nothing else in S Prime
between the path
between the path between the A and C
there's no no terminals S Prime
so just look at the HSN pair UV in S
Prime
and then what we do is like similar to
the warm-up case
at one Edge between a and c yeah
right
what should be the weight of this guy
well
just put them in Max
with the maximum weight between in the
past from A to B in the tree
so in this case 186 you put eight here
do this for every HSN pair
you get some
tree
such that
the number the vertices of H is exactly
X Prime so this 3 is of size
order of s
and it's going to be correct like this
is the correct uh
um
specifier because first about the three
Preserve
the spending Tree Preserve our min max
path
and why like is enough to just do this
case kind of just apply the idea from
the warm-up case
time to construct this this is just to
compute MST which is which is basically
linear time the size is also linear in s
okay so that's like a symbol example how
you construct
vertex specifier Compares it into the
size of the terminal set
okay
next thing I want to talk about is just
one property of call composibility
so
this similarity similarity relation like
I will say it's composable if like when
I said that g is similar s approximate G
with respect to s
and
if you have an edge
UV
whose endpoint both of them are in the
terminal set s
if you have these two thing and the
following is true
then we call we say that the relation is
composible that is
if these two things you have then s
plus an h and G plus an H
still approximate each other with
respect to s
and you can observe that the relation
that you preserve me next PATH yeah it's
composable
um that is I want to show that
if G
print like if H is equivalent to G with
respect to the stamina set then
S Plus and H is equivalent to g plus an
H such when an H has end point
inside the terminal right
okay so why is that it's it's just kind
of amount to checking definition well
um
if you look at for any pair St okay
a min max
uh in the graph
G Plus e
from s to T
um you like what what can it be
well you have a graph an S and T
and then you add some Edge
um
some h e here
after adding an edge
the min max path might not change so it
could be like min max of the old graph
or the min max path might be the one
where
you
go from s to you let's say this is you
and then go from B to T
otherwise it might be another one
which is
go from s to GB first
and from U to T
so this three case
that's how you get like just minimize
over all three cases here that's a min
max
from stt in the graph G Plus e
well the same thing is true for for h
plus e
you have three KS
but once you just compare this thing
like everything every min max of edge is
the same as mid Max of G this min max of
H is the same as min max of G so
so everything here is the same
so you get that min max of
uh
from s to T
are the same in
S Plus e and G Plus e
so that's why you get that h plus e is
equivalent to g plus e
so it's composable
Okay so
many natural uh similarities like
relation approximation relation is
composible
like um this tense is impossible as well
but yeah for today we look at min max
equivalent
okay
good so we get some Basics about vertex
specifier now so let's see uh how
like given an algorithm
for computing vertex specifier
how can you get
Dynamic algorithm
and this is used in like many papers
like
a lot of them like by Grandma's
um
the earliest one that I see is like by
Epstein
um
and it's just also a quite quite a quite
a lot in like the modern Mac flow
algorithms the linear time almost linear
time one as well
so my plan is
to show you this reduction
even a fast algorithm for computing
specifier you get Dynamic algorithm but
I will show the one that gives you the
offline one okay
um
and then discuss a bit how to get how to
make like how the same idea also apply
and give you none offline one the
standard Dynamic algorithm
and
point you out about a bunch of open
problem in this area
but anyway let me tell you first what
what are offline algorithms
so what we will look at is offline
Dynamic algorithm
and just for Simplicity like first like
convenience for notation of notation
whatever we assume right now is like uh
for for every update for each step
instead of giving an update or a query
I'm given two things at the same time
I'm given One update which is which can
be deletion or in session as well as I'm
given some query
as ITI I want to know like what's the
min max between s and t s i and t i
so
the offline fully Dynamic min max path
problem is like this
the input the input
is a whole sequence
of
update in queries
the length of this input is of size m
so when you see this m it means that it
means that at any time
the size of your graph at the graph at
time I
have Atmos M edges trivially just
because the the size of total insertion
is can be at most m
m
and
this is what the point why we call this
offline is because
you are really given the whole input
sequence how like update sequence
this whole update sequence is given to
you in one go and you can read the whole
of this sequence
it's not revealed to you one by one like
before like a standard setting
okay
and what we want to Output is to output
for our I compute mean Max
from SI to TI in the graph GI
so I hope this is clear like what is
offline setting
sometimes it's useful actually to get
offline algorithm
like it can be interesting by itself
but it's weaker than then send that one
and again trivially you can do this in M
Square time
um there are M steps each step you can
compute min max
you can answer the min max query
in linear time so you can do it in M
Square time trivially
to answer that
every every queries
but I will show you how to get this
from into the 1.5 and then M time
at the end
so you can think of this as like
basically almost constant per update
query the total time is M so on average
is almost constant
Okay so
the high level idea that we will proceed
like that we'll try to do is this
imagine that this is a timeline
okay
what what I will do first to answer the
query is actually I want to compute for
every step I
want to compute a specifier
h i
that preserves information about the
graph at time i t i
it preserves information about sinti
about the thing that we want to query
note that the size of H I will have
constant size because the terminal set
here is just two nodes
so given like there are like a graph in
the timeline you compute kind of
smaller graph
that are equivalent for each of the time
and
if you are given this h i here
then you can just compute
min max of s-i-n-t-i-n-t-i just by
Computing this thing in hi
each eye you can compute this in
constant time so the total time to to
return all this thing for our I is just
linear
so
from The Edge okay if you have computed
h i you can compute all this thing
for all I in linear time
so this is indeed enough for you to do
but what's what's the way how to how to
compute the specifier
well a terrible way to compute specify
is just like to spend linear time to
come to h i for each specifier
that takes M Square time which is not
good
and the high level idea less trivial way
to do this is to do some like
hierarchical decomposition of the
timeline
what what will happen and I will go into
details this is just like a schematic
thing
um
just we just decompose the timeline into
Parts into interval of length root m
the root M interval
and for each of this interval we will do
something in linear time
and then
for each of the interval here you will
get like a the h i within the interval
um
but the time to compute each of this h i
here will be just root M instead of
linear
so there will be two level of things
for each level you stand into the 1.5
times
that's high level uh idea will you
explicitly specify what are they I would
make this into like a very details here
yeah
let's see the details now
okay to make two
do this I need some notation
Okay so
okay we we divide the update sequence of
length m
right into root M intervals
okay there are intervals here
and let's fix one interval I
set this one interval
now
this is just just some interval of the
timeline now for each Edge in the graph
one Edge will be inserted and delete
so that like there is like a
interval time lifetime of each age right
so for each he
that would be like
interval of e is just an insert time of
e until the time of e each s is like one
one interval
[Music]
and
once you define the interval of NH I can
define a permanent Edge
with respect to an interval I the red
interval here
this is just an ish such that it stay
for the whole interval
so the interval of I contains this I2
the interval of an H in contains I2 so
this kind of H that stay permanently
within this red interval is a permanent
one
another one is the not permanent one or
the updated one
this is just an edge such that
it has some overlap with with I
with this interval
but
it is like
it's not like it's not permanent so the
intersection of I and the interval of an
H
is not it's up
it's like it overlap is not empty but
it's not this intersection is not the
whole thing okay
and the way you should think about these
two set the permanent Edge
the size of the permanent Ash could be
as big as m in the worst case can be
linear
but
what's the size of the updated one
it's at most root m
right because the length of I2 here
itself is of size root M so it can have
on only like a root root a mini updated
edges
you're right thanks yeah
um this thing should be
that's how it can yeah
okay
so this
these two are fine right
yeah we need some notation but yeah
now
when you look at this interval I2 yeah
and given this notation I will Define
the terminal set
for I2 for this red interval
before reading this you can you should
think of that interval the Tomato set
for I
think of it as like endpoint of
edges that are updated or endpoint of
the of the query so it everything that
kind of the endpoint
that are related to to the interval okay
whether it's updated or query
so
which means that is the end point
of the updated edges during the interval
I
and also the end point of all the
queries
osita within the interval I
this terminal set is of size root M2
because
there are like root M update and queries
so you can think like you have a graph
and if you look at some interval I I2
there can be some updated H within I2
some query
and
yeah the Intel terminals for I2 is just
all this endpoint
so now we are ready to describe the
algorithm
what we're going to do is this
the algorithm gonna Loop through all the
interval here
put the interval here
let's look at one
one interval
let's say I
what I'm gonna do first
is to compute
a graph
sub I
h of the interval I
this graph will be equivalent
to the permanent ish
for for Interval I
with respect to the terminal set
so
you have this graph
okay you look at this terminal set here
and forget about the green thing because
these are not permanent
and you compute the
like the specifier
h i that is that preserve information
about permanent Edge for for Interval I
H I would have size
root m
why because your your terminal set is of
size root M so this is where compression
is going on like the permanent edges can
have linear size but you compress it to
to root m
size
so this is just a graph for one
terminals like graph h i is for this
whole terminal for interval
okay
now for each step
small I
let's say like you look at step I
I'm gonna create one graph
s i Prime
okay
how how is it how does it look like
so
it's gonna it's either the graph where I
just kind of
start with h i okay
it's a graph
where I look at an edge
that is updated within okay I look at an
edge in GI
that is not permanent
and add it to to h i
okay so what is an edge in Edge is just
all edges that intersect with this
vertical line right this these are not
in
what is uh what are the edges in GI
or edges that intersect with with this
vertical line
these two are not in GI
okay these two I don't care
so I look at this one that are not
permanent so it's only these two guys
and I add these two guys into
into h i and get h i Prime
so in picture
um
it's like
you look at
this edges that are updated within this
big interval the green one are updated
in the green interval but not everything
is in GI so let's set only two guys here
is NTI
that's the guys that I add into into hi
and get h i Prime
and now that's
so h i Prime is just kind of a graph
where I kind of add an edge that is
specific to GI
2s to s i
and once I have this graph this graph is
still of size like of size root m
the last step I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna build Edge item
the one that I want it's just gonna be
the specifier of h i Prime with respect
to
s-i-n-t-i
so I would get from this I compress it
further to a graph that have size
constant
so h i was a tree but H little I prime
is not
I
is a tree
big I
um
yes yeah yeah this one is a tree Once
you add some edges it's not in three
it's not a tree
good yeah
right you should think of this as a tree
and you add some edges so it's not a
tree anymore
so h i Prime is not a tree and then you
compress it to just one h
so
a lot of notation but once we see the
correctness proof I hope like you are
convinced that like this makes sense
so
first thing
like my goal is to show that okay
H I would be equivalent to g i
with respect to
the end point
if this is true then we are done right
this is what we want to compute for
every eye
there are two steps the first step is
I'm gonna show first step
at least
s i Prime
Preserve
CI
okay plus I Prime
preserve GI
h i Prime is not like Asthma as h i yet
but it's preserved GI
so why is that
well because first of all we have that
um
the graph s big I
is
like is equivalent to the permanent one
but
by composibility right
if you add some set of edges to both
sides of this thing
this and this
they must still be equivalent
but now from the definition
h i Prime is this thing
h i Prime is just this thing
so this is just h i Prime
and what is this thing
this is just GI exactly so it's
this set Union with ti minus
so h i Prime is equivalent to GI with
respect to it
as big I
okay so we we have at least we have
halfway that this guy
is equivalent to GI okay but what we
want is like we want h i
to be equivalent to GI
but
why is that
well
I want to show this name if we have this
we are done
well we have that s i and h i Prime is
equivalent to each other with respect to
S1 and T1 s i and t i this is from the
definition here from how we build it
but
but as I Prime
is equivalent to GI
right
so
because this thing is equivalent
equivalent to each other with respect to
the bigger set as I
so it would be equal and with respect to
this just two points here too
so this equivalent to this this thing
equal into this so they are equivalent
to each other like h i and G I are
equivalent to each other
so that finished the proof
um
question about this
yep
each integral take um quarter M instead
of a Quarter Square them
you can do just brute force and to
reduce the permanent edges
like this is basically brush Force
within the interval
each other time inside the interval you
just add what you need to add for each
of the specific I
and you just compute
um
yeah you could have you just you could
have just computed inside
I want to do this just because it will
be clear that from this you can
compose you can compose and make it more
than two levels yeah
good question yeah
yes so this works for any composable
relation right this works for any
composable relation and uh the second
question is within the interval why
can't you records instead of doing this
good for
food
um you could vote fast what what I'm
describing here is to actually kind of
recurse
I'm just kind of fold
like a unfold the the recursion into to
follow
I can just describe it as a recursion I
just unfolded the regression into two
font
okay
so
let's analyze the time right well the uh
load and many Loops yeah
this step takes linear time
so this like this total time is like M
em root m
about this one the total Loop that you
go through this is m
but each of the steps here text root M
time
so the total time is M to 1.5
um
yeah you can yeah
you compute an ms3 and just Compares it
to one one one Edge yeah
yeah okay so this is a schematic thing
that kind of I put like I extend the
details
um
you get like these two level things
in enter the 1.5 time
but
okay two level
of specifier give you this running time
if you have K levels instead
you would just you know like
divide this thing further into intervals
um
and apply the same idea
and adjust the parameter instead of root
M you make it balance
if you have K level of specify you could
just you will get like the total time of
M to the one plus one over k
and okay not that
when you compute like if the specify is
not exact if it has approximation Alpha
when you compute specifier of a
specifier
this approximation
would accumulate to Alpha to the K where
K is the level of things
okay
but you would get Alpha to Decay
approximation of flight Dynamic
algorithms
but in our case Alpha is one we get we
have accept specifier so there's nothing
to worry about you could just set K to
be logged in
and that's how you like how you get
near linear time
so what you just seen
is that
um
it's a black box transformation right it
works as long as you like if you have
a text specifier
a faster algorithm to compete with
expensive fire
and the like the relation
is compostable
immediately you would get offline fully
Dynamic algorithm from this
how to not get just offline one
um
we can do it and
it's gonna be super similar and but
like it just add like a some orientation
and makes them
the
presentation more complicated but the
idea is just similar
so let me just claim what is true and
you can try to do it as an exercise to
convince yourself that is but that it
works
that is if
your vertex specifier algorithm
could handle this thing or that I call
the add terminal operation
what is is it's like operation where
like okay you compute vertex specify
with respect to some set s
and let's say you have one more one more
node you want to put into in terminal
let's call it
V
you want to add B into your terminal set
if you can do this thing and like you
add me into your terminal set and you
can't update your specifier quickly like
let's say poly lock time
that's that's like what it means by like
you you support a terminal operation
and many if you can do this you
immediately would get incremental
algorithm
online one not offline
and by the way like many specifiers many
known specifiers in the literature
including let's say the one for that
preserved This Time by Taurus week
that one naturally support at the
terminal
at Terminal operation
other ones like uh some something else
called regulatory that preserve mag flow
that also naturally support this so it's
like you get this for free most of the
time and you get incremental algorithm
If instead but now if instead you are
vertex specifier can handle both at
Terminal operation and delete operation
I'm going to go into details but
um you could expect that if you can
handle both atiminal inhalation you
would get fully Dynamic algorithm
in the Black Box way too
so how fast do you want those operations
proportional to s or uh
it should it should not be proportion to
S it should be independent of s it's
like if you add one terminal you should
spend let's say 40 lock time
if you spend like the time to
do this is something like T
the average update time here like the
worst case of that time here would be t
just proportion to
like you start with something fast here
you get the same update time here
so for example for a min max you know
the degree could be large no inside as
so you make some other assumptions about
pre-processing or something
um
the degree could be large
yeah you're right
um let me add a new vertex and I have a
new pass through this is what is for
everybody
no I mean
what other assumptions
yeah good question
um
yeah like them
okay the the way to do it is to make
the graph constantly green there will be
some reduction to make it
to make that is like to make that true
like but that comes a kind of offside
outside of the Black Box yeah yeah
okay
okay and
but at least I hope you see the whole
thing like you saw the whole thing of
this one
and um
this one you you could try to do it
yourself
um
not complicated
so now let me mention some some Owen
problems in this area related to Dynamic
vertex classifier
so there are a lot and I think it's
quite promising
um
I'm gonna put a huge table here
and the red highlight below would like
highlight the aspect that can be
improved
and you don't you're not supposed to
read the whole thing you can look up
later and see if like if you want to
work on it
and basically
like so we saw me next one
um we started offline vertex classifier
the static one
one can make it fully Dynamic that is it
handled both atom you know and
and as well as delete
so
this is one of
um my previous work so you could like
this is kind of self
but for shortest path
for example
um
like
you you could you you we have this like
trade off which is
this is like expected to be optimal
however this trade-off
you have we have the dynamic
uh what you specify only in the
incremental case you can handle only add
terminal
so you get only incremental algorithm
from it
if this is fully Dynamic you can handle
if you can handle deletion too you would
immediately
uh get fully Dynamic design Oracle which
is pretty nice
and many other things here
um so you can look up in the video and
uh
so if you want to work on it I think
it's it's a nice area like it's a nice
question about yourself
and it has a good application
these are all underrated graphs yes
when you say good application meaning
you get the dynamic you get these
Dynamic elements
okay right right yes
um not yeah just just inside this thing
yeah inside
Dynamic area
okay
so uh
what you have seen so far right
um is like a three templates
of dynamic data structure
along the way like we set ups like we
you now know like a basic terminology in
the area
uh the first template is something like
this
uh rebuild in the background
second one is the how to get from one
batch algorithm to Dynamic algorithm
that one bash algorithm usually is
easier to design
once you just
apply it to a review in the background
technique you get the enemy algorithms
and note that it works for our care bash
algorithm too and this K batch thing
have been used and applied to to get
like more Dynamic algorithm
in the literature
last thing is for text specifier idea
there are more templates that I would
not have time to talk about
and the reason and quite promising uh
templates
is
the thing that Aaron mentioned in in the
introduction of this Workshop actually
which is
two
to get like to start with some
optimization method
that is suitable
for dynamic algorithm
for example he mentioned that like
something like liquid lies solution
there are ways
to compute static solution it's not
Dynamic it's just a static solution
that itself is kind of robust enough
against update
you should think like if you compute
floor
it kind of balance your flow such that
each installation will not delete a lot
of your flow something like that
um just compute static solution that is
good enough like that is robust against
update and you can show that
just by rebuilding the static solution
that is robust enough against update you
don't need to review too often
something like that
so
much more thing to explore here and I
think it's exciting
or
there are ways to dynamize the
optimization method itself
like to make multiplicative with update
dynamic
there are works on this thing quite
recently
and also even into the appointment
thought
one can minimize that thing by itself
and get new Dynamic algorithm for
example they get
Dynamic algorithm for exact neck flow in
the incremental case
and there are more templates in the
literature that maybe like
um
not like I don't have time to go through
like
there are say like given incremental
algorithm you can get fully Dynamic
offline
but this is like um this template gives
you only like offline only so
um
there are some
um specific uh template like a template
that is quite specific to some problem
like if you have decremental algorithm
you can get fully Dynamic algorithms
and there are like some Works some work
in in the past
like in the 80s
showing that
for many geometric algorithm symmetric
problems that are composible in some
sense
if the problem is composable
that is that automatically is a fully
Dynamic algorithm
something like this
and um
okay
let's see wait a second
[Music]
I want to like tell you quickly about
what I'm gonna talk about next time
so
the first thing is just a pointer
um
to what is what I will not cover
okay
um so
that like recently that there is like um
quite
nice technique that's on expander
that can be applied to many Dynamic
problems like Dynamic connectivity such
as path
in both underwritten and directed graph
and um this is based on expanded
partitioning or expanded pruning
and I have given like a tutorial about
this thing
um
and you can look up and that is like the
whole course related to this too if you
want to learn a lot about this
there is
one techniques that I want to mention
because
it's a technique for matching problem
it works for dynamic meshing but what is
so interesting about this technique is
called
H degree constraint subgraph
what is so interesting about this this
technique is that is a technique that
applies in so many areas not just
dynamic
but streaming
algorithm
and communication and so on so it kind
of a model independent technique so if
you want to work on meshing this is
something to look at
and Aaron gave a tutorial on this and I
put a link and I will upload the slides
yes
thanks Aaron Bernstein
yeah
okay
another one like
um it's called randomized Grady this is
like a general approach that works very
well for
like
for symmetric uh symmetry breaking
problems like maximal matching maximal
independent set
um
it's like a one technique that
likely will work to more problems and
you can have a look at sohail's uh
tutorial
what I will talk about next in the next
talk
is
to focus on
adversaries
so
when you use Dynamic algorithm
and interact with
optimization method
now you need to care whether like this
interaction is adaptive or not
and so
in next talk you will learn a different
kind of adversaries
there are many kinds actually
and you will see templates again like
template of Designing algorithm
for different kind of adversary
and I think that would conclude
for today thanks
[Applause]
thank you questions
uh hello
um so I just had a question on the
triplet three like the vertex sparsifier
um I want to ask is like the method of
like splitting between like permanent
non-permanent edges does that also work
for
different composable like different
composable structures for example like
Edge star suppliers like can you also do
that to create dynamic dynamic
algorithms
so uh the question is like
this composible will take specifier
um wait if you have a specifier that is
composable would it give you some
Dynamic algorithm
um yes usually like there is like a work
called
um
specification by F Stein at all like in
the 90s like 97
which really like use this idea however
the speed up that you will get is gonna
be like
it's kind of looks like this
you have if you have algorithm that have
running time depends on M
you can replace it with running time
that depends on n
so just like kind of more modest
um speed up
for questions
okay let's think about again
so we're not done for the day